the 10 last welcome wagon has arrived i
see on social media you're a big fan of
ted lasso would you be interested in
like having a role on that show
absolutely even a cameo i mean walk by
kind of out of focus just anything i
love that show in the meantime it may
not be long before reba is back on tv
this year marks the 20th anniversary of
her sidcom reba and it seems a reunion
may be in the works
what in the heck do you think you're
doing well right now i'm wondering why
we chose this color grout
how close are we to actually getting
you guys back together to do
a revived revisited version of reba
that's a great idea well we've all
talked about it we would love to do it
and again timing is everything so you've
got to wait until all the
planets are lined up and ducks in a row
and be ready to present it so we're uh
we're all talking about it
[Music]
but for now reba fans are celebrating
the release of revived remix revisited a
three-part box set of reba's most iconic
songs that have been reimagined which
includes a new duet with dolly parton
[Music]
it looked like
anyone that would have been on set that
day this is like a
milestone moment for them did it feel
like that for you or did it really just
feel like two friends just hanging out
it was both it was a milestone moment
for me
absolutely without a doubt and then just
hanging out with your buddy
i mean timing is everything and
everything happens for a reason but we
enjoyed it tremendously
[Music]